mais d'abord les enjeux de la coop 26 à
glasgow les états commencent à afficher
leurs nouveaux engagements en matière
notamment de réduction des gaz à effet
de serre ou de lutte contre la
déforestation gaspard flamand les
premières mesures de la coop 26 sont
actés pour limiter le réchauffement
climatique au niveau mondial plus de 80
pays se sont engagés à réduire de 30%
d'ici 2030 leurs émissions de méthane un
puissant gaz à effet de serre autre
engagement enrayer la déforestation 100
pays dont le brésil et les états unis
promettent de protéger les forêts
les états unis aideront le monde à
atteindre notre objectif commun
d'arrêter la perte naturelle des forêts
et de restaurer au moins 200 millions
d'hectares supplémentaires de forêt et
d'autres écosystèmes d'ici 2030
ce plan est le premier du genre et il
s'agit d'une approche de l'ensemble du
gouvernement
autre enjeu important de cette coop 26
l'aide des pays riches les plus gros
pollueurs aux pays pauvres pour les
aider à faire face à la crise climatique
100 milliards de dollars par an ont été
promis à partir de 2023 aujourd'hui il
est à peu près certain que les pays
d'afrique du pacifique de l'amérique
latine amérique du sud et des caraïbes
qui en ont le plus besoin ne sont pas
ceux qui touchent le plus nous le savons
ces financements
est donc au-delà de nos annonces nous
devons aussi avoir une transparence sur
le suivi de l'utilisation de ces 100
milliards de dollars par an du côté des
associations et des ong plus que des
paroles ce sont des actes concrets qui
sont attendus en marge du sommet des
militants d'oxfam ont mis en scène
l'arrivée des dirigeants mondiaux à
glasgow avec un message plus de volonté
politique alors que les dirigeants du
monde entier arrivent à glasgow la
dernière chose dont nous avons besoin ce
sont deux discussions tiède ou du vent
ce dont nous avons besoin ce sont des
actes nous avons besoin d'action pour
réduire considérablement les émissions
de carbone dès maintenant toutes ces
mesures ont pour but de limiter le
réchauffement de la planète à un degré
et demi car pour l'instant la
trajectoire donne une hausse de 2,7
degrés d'ici la fin du siècle
l'accord 26 au delà des promesses
comment les transformer en actes
justement c'est le thème de notre débat
je vous présente mes invités sofia kbs
bonjour bienvenue vous êtes chercheuse
au sein du pôle climat énergie et
sécurité de l'iris fabrice bonnifet
bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi directeur
développement durable et tué ceux du
groupe oui vous êtes le président du
collège des directeurs du développement
durable c3d s'améliorer bonsoir
bienvenue responsable du plaidoyer à la
fondation nicolas hulot et j'accueille
également frédéric salissement par un
éditorialiste politique à france culture
qui sera à mes côtés ce soir et je dis
évidemment comme les autres
éditorialistes vous intervenez quand
vous voulez dans le débat plus vous
parlez je sais je sais je vous le dise
ça de ça devrait aller tout seul
peut-être un point un peu générale de ce
que vous attendez les uns et les autres
de cette coop 26 à glasgow je disais au
delà des promesses parce que des
promesses d'un politique sofia kbj rang
de chef d'état y en a eu pas mal depuis
ces dernières années oui il y en a eu
pas mal et après ce qu que ça quand on
regarde en fait comment se sont traduit
les engagements en actes alors
aujourd'hui la coop 26 allées importante
pourquoi pas ce qu'on demande aux états
de rehausser leurs ambitions réhaussé
leurs ambitions dans le cadre de
l'accord de paris en maître si vous
voulez la foulée cinq ans exactement une
sorte de deux mécanismes on demande aux
états à chaque fois d'être de plus en
plus ambitieux le problème c'est pour ça
que la coop sa part nous interrompt sa
peine 26 parce qu'ils prennent des
engagements pour l'année dans cinq ans à
venir la coop s'appelle 26 parce que
c'est la 26e fois ok par utilise donc
les signataires de la coupe de la
convention cadre des nations unies se
réunissent sur 25 mesures voile alors
lisez mon côté j'ai donc durant cette
coupe 26 on attendait et acquérir cette
ambition donc ces fameuses feuilles de
route lorsqu'on vient analyser ce à quoi
que ce soit engagée pour l'instant donc
dans le cas de la coop 26 on est à + 16
% d'émissions d'ici à 2030 le giec nous
recommande être à -45% démissionne donc
on a un écart qui est quand même
conséquent ça c'est la première chose la
deuxième chose c'est qu'en fait depuis
2000 15 des émissions continuer à
augmenter on atteint chaque année de
nouveaux records de concentration de gaz
à effet de serre dans l'atmosphère donc
on se rend bien compte que entre les
promesses qui sont faites et les actes
il ya un grand écart ensuite sur le
financement
du juste avant dans le reportage les
fameux 100 milliards c'est 100 milliards
ils ne sont pas nouveaux ils ont été ré
entériné dans l'accord de paris il avait
déjà été
en 2009 est donc là ils s'engagent à les
atteindre en 2023 mais la date limite
c'était 2020 et ça c'est crucial pour
les états développés en développement
pardon pour leur permettre justement la
mise en place des politiques
d'atténuation d'adaptation surtout
nécessaire et puis enfin l'article 6 de
l'accord de paris c'est celui qui va un
petit peu en fait fixer le cadre du
marché carbone internationale et des
mécanismes de compensation ça bloque
depuis de nombreuses années sur sa mise
en oeuvre mais justement c'est un outil
qui considéré comme indispensable pour
pour les atteindre on pourra peut-être
en discuter après mais pourquoi ça
bloque et comment faire quand j'entends
votre premier constat on pourrait
presque dire à quoi ça sert qu'est ce
que vous en pensez fabrice bonnifet quoi
ça sert à attirer l'attention sur le
fait qu'ils avaient il ya un vrai
problème ça sert au moins à ça
maintenant je partage le constat de ce
que vient de partager un instant
premiers invités
si on continue au rythme actuel on va
vers je crois les spécialistes dire 10,1
un réchauffement de deux degrés 7 alors
à la fin du siècle en cours et donc en
termes de réduction de ce qu'il faudrait
pouvoir faire tous les ans est de
l'ordre de 7% par an donc l'équivalent
de plus d'un kobe de parents en termes
de
diminution de l'économie parce que c'est
ça que ça veut dire et donc c'est comme
être papa rend désirable cet objectif
c'est compliqué pour les politiques
d'expliquer ça en fait parce que quand
on regarde la cause primaire du pourquoi
on n'agit pas en fait pourquoi les états
n'agissent pas c'est que vous avez à les
20 à 30% des pays dans le monde qui sont
exportateur net d'énergie fossile et qui
parce qu'elles n'ont pas mis en cause
leur ait connue depuis des années vivent
essentiellement de lors de leurs
exportations l'essentiel des novices
qu'il récupère cesser la vente d'une
hogra et puis les pays importateurs pour
les mêmes raisons ont besoin de cette
énergie pour faire tourner les machines
pour faire tourner la machine donc en
fait tout le monde a besoin de l'autre
et de laisser sous terre
la moitié des énergies d'énergies
fossiles restantes c'est quelque part
aujourd'hui contenu
mixte énergétique mondiale c'est à 83%
carbonée c'est renoncer à une manne
financière
gigantesque et les banques aujourd'hui
si elle devait considérer des actifs
pétroliers ou gaziers comme échoué parce
qu'on ne peut pas les exploiter ça
mettrait quand même aussi gravement en
péril leur bilan donc la sobriété
économiques sont en fait il s'agit de ça
c'est pas quelque chose qui est facile
d'expliquer aux gens en fait et c'est
pour ça c'est pourtant c'est pourtant
l'enjeu d'arriver à reconfigurer une
économie de la sobriété qui soit vivable
et désirable et qui soit surtout
socialement juste et c'est ça c'est ça
qui est passionnant s'améliorer c'est
que c'est un changement de modèle en
fait mais qu'il faut accepter et c'est
pas si facile de l'accepter la question
c'est à quel vitesse avec quelle
violence avec quelle violence sociale on
change de modèle mais c'est exactement
ça l'enjeu de cette cave ou dédiés à
quoi ça sert la coop elle sert à ce que
tous les états chaque année normalement
reviennent et remettre leurs engagements
donc on a quand même un beau coup de
projecteur sur les engagements de chaque
état et abandonnés chaque état doit
aussi revenir devant leur opinion
publique pour expliquer pourquoi est-ce
qu'elle n'avance pas pourquoi ils ne
respectent pas leurs engagements
pourquoi est-ce qu'ils ne revoient pas
l'abs est là pour rester sur le sujet
précisément la coop ce qui se passait
quelque chose d'intéressant il ya avec
l'inde l'inde qui était un des seuls
pays du g20 qui avait justement pas revu
à la hausse son ambition la revue est
aussi a mis un gros coup de projecteur
sur la responsabilité des pays du nord
parce qu'ils ont dit nous on est prêts à
la neutralité carbone est d'ailleurs
l'un de nous souvent on prendre des
engagements leccia on les tient en amont
très lointain alors pardon mais pour le
coup l'inde c'est plus d'un milliard
d'habitants et 50 % des indiens n'a pas
accès à l'électricité ou alors qu'une ou
deux heures par jour dont il ya des
enjeux de développement si on vivait
coûtent tous comme les indiens et son
ami dé tous deux que les indiens n'y
aurait pas de problème on n'aura pas
besoin d'organiser des coptes donc la
responsabilité de l'un des historiques
par exemple est beaucoup moins forte
mais ce qu'elle dira ça vous choque pas
qu'ils prennent un engagement pour 2060
et devra forcément elle fondera
forcément interrogé mais ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'ils disent nous on
tiendra nos objectifs à vous payer du
nord de tenir nos objectifs une
financiers et c'est là le nerf de la
guerre et c'est pour ça qu'on a des cop
et progresser important de ce club c'est
que les pays du sud disent nous on est
prêts à nous engager mais on a besoin
que vous payez du nord vous tenez vos
objectifs et force est de constater que
les états du nord les pays les plus
riches n'ont pas tenu leurs promesses de
100 milliards à 200 milliards de dollars
par an ils ont refait la promesse pour
dix ans en 2023 on va y arriver mais
cette promesse avait été faite à
copenhague en 2009 et on n'a pas été
capable de le tenir et donc là il ya une
grosse responsabilité de pays du nord y
compris la france et l'union européenne
alors on entend tous les pourcentages
comme ça parfois même on s'y perd en
termes de pourcentage de baisse
d'émissions de co2 sur les années à
venir question toute bête qui mesure est
ce que ce sont les pays eux-mêmes auquel
cas ils peuvent plus ou moins s'arranger
avec la vérité et surtout qui contrôle
ça ça pose la question des malades et
des mesures des labels et finalement de
du constat de départ pour se donner une
trajectoire d'une certaine façon ça mais
le rêve ou
des éléments dans le cadre de l'accord
de paris un mécanisme de vérification
donc les états communiquent leur feuille
de route sont les fameuses contribution
des terminaux niveau national qui sont
faites par les organismes nationaux et
puis ensuite c'est contributions font
l'objet d'une révision chaque et alors
on peut pas réviser les 196 partie sans
plus l'union européenne en même temps et
donc ça fait l'objet de révisions année
en année ceci étant dit en effet ça pose
des soucis notamment en termes de
capacité de comparaison parce que
parfois les contributions ne sont pas
faites à la même échelle temporelle
c'est à dire qu'on ne s'engage pas sur
le même temps certains à 2030 2050 avec
pas le même comparatif possible si on
dit par rapport à 1990 n'est pas la même
chose que par rapport à 2010 donc il ya
des mesures de vérification
ceci étant dit par exemple pour les
entreprises c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué c'est beaucoup c'est fait de
manière beaucoup plus autonome avec
parfois des organismes indépendants en
blouson noir de l'entreprise et puis des
notamment des pays bien sûr dans les
pays développés on a quand même beaucoup
plus de capacités les entreprises ont
beaucoup plus de fonds aussi à investir
dans certains pays en développement
c'est plus compliqué de réaliser ce
qu'on appelle les bilans carbone de
suivre ce bilan carbone à et puis tout
simplement de mettre en oeuvre la
méthodologie nécessaire en fait pour
l'analyser sur les différents périmètres
des entreprises voilà alors c'est un
enjeu par exemple européen fabrice
bonnifet c'est cette question du
thermomètre c'est ce qu'on appelle la
taxonomie donc c'est un peu compliqué
c'est un mot qui qui
débarque dans notre vocabulaire
médiatique depuis quelques années il
faut expliquer ce que c'est la taxonomie
et surtout quel impact elle va avoir sur
le financement de notre économie
européenne dans les prochaines années la
taxonomie c'était une nouvelle règle du
jeu il s'impose à un grand nombre
d'entreprises cotées notamment mais pas
seulement des grandes entreprises on
leur demande de classifier leurs
activités en pour faire simple en deux
catégories celles qui sont considérées
comme verte pourrait qu'ils répondent à
une scie conditions dont deux conditions
sur le climat l'atténuation l'adaptation
et puis les activités qui sont grise ou
brune et qui rentrent pas dans les
critères de la beauté de de performance
environnementale et donc les entreprises
pour la première année là sont en train
de faire de ces classifications
telle activité rentrer dans la bonne
case par exemple si vous faites des
fermes solaires photovoltaïque flottante
si vous êtes plutôt de bons côtés si
vous faites
des voitures thermiques qui émettent
beaucoup de co2 vous n'êtes pas dans la
même catégorie avec ce club est donc là
tout l'enjeu c'est effectivement de
flécher les financements
donc les banques notamment puissent
prioritairement mais ce n'est pas une
obligation c'est là qu'on le reverra les
limites de cette réglementation flèche
sera donc et les finances seront fléchés
dans les activités dites vertes en
priorité donc on sait pas comment
exactement ça va fonctionner pour
l'instant les entreprises sont en train
de faire cette classification des
activités éligibles puis ensuite tu
auras l'alignement sur les huit
objectifs environnementaux qui ont été
fixées par la commission il restera pas
grand chose en fait dans dans le dans le
modèle économique des boîtes on en sait
on appelait ceux qui ont commencé à
jouer à anticiper en fête avec ses
traits avec cette nouvelle
réglementation les plus chanceux d'entre
elles c'est 70% et puis la plupart c'est
plutôt vers 25 % d'activité économique
donc ça fait une grande partie de
l'économie qui est pas éligible et
qu'est ce qu'on va faire des gens qui
travaillent dans ces industries là
qu'est ce qu'on va en faire on va leur
dire de l'été était plus tu travailles
plus dans une activité qui qui a de
l'avenir ben il va falloir reconfigurer
tout ça et on voit dans l'industrie
automobile par exemple à tous ceux qui
fabrique des boîtes de vitesse qui
forment des voitures thermiques quand on
sait qu'il y aura plus de voitures
thermiques en vente à partir de 2035
dans l'union européenne mais qu'est ce
qu'on fait de ses usines comment on va
les démanteler comment on va former les
gens qui travaillent les sous traitants
aussi les chaîne de sous traitance donc
c'est des pans entiers de l'économie qui
vont devoir se réinventer pour aller
vers d'autres types d'activités mais
lesquels donc c'est un enjeu qui est qui
est énorme sur ce sujet assez important
parce que j'ai quand même un vrai sujet
d'actualité aujourd'hui puisque la
question elle est aussi de savoir
qu'est-ce qu'on définit comme vers l'est
les définitions sont pas encore calé et
donc il ya le sujet du moment la
révélation c'est que la france soutient
que le gaz et le nucléaire seraient des
énergies vertes et donc pour défendre le
nucléaire la france s'est allié avec la
pologne la hongrie donc toutes les
démocraties on a le gouvernement qui
prend souvent la parole pour les
annoncer comme béral s'allie avec eux
pour justement inclure le gaz dans la
taxonomie comme les énergies vertes
alors que c'est quelque chose de très
facile et qu'on a besoin d'arrêter
complètement les financements et publics
et privés sur ce sujet donc là c'est
aussi ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure sur
la question des double discours et des
engagements c'est compliqué d'aller à la
coop à glasgow d'un côté et de dire il
faut sortir des énergies fossiles et de
donner la leçon un peu à tous les états
en disant vous devez revoir à la hausse
nos engagements et dans le même temps
dire à bruxelles abba nous on veut que
le gaz soit dans les énergies vertes
pour tous les énergies pour toutes les
énergies des investissements et publics
et privés d'avenir donc là ce double
discours la france elle en est
responsable il va falloir assez
rapidement sortir parce que ça c'est des
choses qui bloque les négociations aussi
les états quand on discutait entre les
états du nord et les états du sud quand
on voit qu'un état comme la france tient
ce double discours entre ce qui est fait
en europe et en france et dans les
négociations internationales et danse à
bloc et ça ne m'est pas le climat de
confiance qui est nécessaire pour
arriver à un accord ambitieux à glasgow
alors ça nous amène sur le on va parler
évidemment du bilan d' emmanuel macron
sur sur ce quinquennat mais peut-être
sadek saillie sur la sobriété des
des politiques pendant cette campagne
présidentielle qui qui démarre sur aubry
y était vraiment est ce qu ils font une
campagne qui tient compte voilà de ses
engagements oui ou non les services de
trouver quelques critères oui
socialement intéressant sobriété pas ça
il a changé de sens ces dernières années
devant l'urgence climatique dati s'est
teinté de ce sens davantage écologie la
sobriété c'est l'énergie qu'on ne
consomme pas c'est la meilleure énergie
on entend souvent ce slogan or on voit
régulièrement dans ses coffres des
militants ou des opposants politiques si
c'est des polémiques sur le fait qu'il
ya beaucoup d'avions qui a beaucoup de
voitures on a vu john dryden à rome
quelques jours avant la com' 26 avec ses
80 véhicules thermiques les scores du
président américain qui est classique
alors évidemment c'est un peu facile
c'est un peu caricatural de dire ça
néanmoins on peut se poser la question
ce qui va se passer pendant cette
campagne présidentielle est ce que
certains candidats qui prône la sobriété
énergétique vont se l'appliquer à
eux-mêmes et auquel cas c'est pas si
simple parce que le pouvoir a une
dimension de faste de démonstration de
puissance vous devez avoir une plus de
militants que les autres vous avez des
sales illuminé avec des écrans géants
vous faites venir des militants en
quarts de l'autre bout de la france
c'est assez peu sobre énergétiquement et
ceux qui vont décider de le faire vont
peut-être être désavantagé par rapport à
ceux qui ne sont pas du tout en
regardant alors on a actuellement un
quota maximal de dépenses pour les
comptes de campagne ça vient sur le
volet financier vous n'avez pas le droit
de dépenser plus de 22 millions d'euros
par campagne est-ce qu'on ne pourrait
pas avoir dans l'avenir pas pour
maintenant une sorte de quotas co2 pour
chacun des candidats qui soit à la fois
responsable et qu'ils puissent faire
cette campagne de manière équitable et
durable et il est peut-être le plus
c'est arnaud montebourg qui fait sa
campagne hier en ter exactement donc là
je pensais le hcc pacific coast
quelques-unes des des cases
j'aurais que jonathan dupriez ce nouveau
gène je pense qu'il doit pas être très
très loin juste juste derrière en
coulisses je vois ses pieds derrière
vous pouvez venir pour nous informer sur
le le sénat jonathan qui qui s'est
emparée de ce sujet de la coop 26 sous
la forme d'une résolution à faire un peu
de pédagogie parlementaire c'est quoi
une ride je vais vous expliquer
peut-être en deux mots ce que c'est une
résolution ça doit pas parler à tout le
monde en fait pour faire simple thomas
c'est lorsqu'un ou plusieurs groupes
politiques du sénat décide lui-même en
fait de débattre d'un sujet d'un texte
dans l'hémicycle un qu'on peut voter
aussi sur un sujet évidemment du choix
de ces groupes politiques au menu du
jour donc c'est une surprise pour
personne la coop 26 de glasgow les
sénateurs ont voulu en quelque sorte
faire un peu leur kop dans l'hémicycle
et l'unisson ils ont plaidé pour je cite
un accord ambitieux pour qu'un accord
justement ambitions en découlent sauf
que ce vote de cette résolution
contrairement à la loi eh bien il n'est
pas contraignant alors il n'empêche que
les échanges sans surprise ont été
l'occasion pour les parlementaires de
rappeler l'urgence d'agir contre le
réchauffement climatique comme l'a
souligné didier mandelli qui est l'un
des co auteurs de la résolution en
reprenant les mots d'antonio gouttière s
écouter
il est temps de dire assez assez de
brutaliser la biodiversité
assez de nous tuer nous mêmes avec le
carbone assez de traiter la nature comme
des toilettes assez de brûler forêt
extraire toujours plus profond nous
creusons nos propres tombes
ces mots ont été prononcés par antonio
guterres est secrétaire général de l'onu
à glasgow pour l'ouverture d'un kop 26
il y à quelques heures
près de cinquante ans après le premier
sommet de la terre à stockholm c'est
montrent une cause particulière ils
traduisent l'urgence climatique
on pourrait se dire à quoi ça sert
franchement des démos par-dessus démoli
d'aider les sénateurs c'est quoi de
faire bloc derrière la délégation
française symboliquement c'est
exactement ça en fait depuis la côte 21
la france qui se placent un peu en
garante des accords de paris c'est à
dire limiter le réchauffement bien en
deçà des 2 degrés d'ici la fin du siècle
il ya aussi le fait qu emmanuel macron
se place lui-même un revendiquent
souvent lui même ce leadership en
matière d'écologie sur le plan
international et même si nous mêmes nous
n'avons pas rempli tous les objectifs
fixés par l'accord de paris 1 je
rappelle que l'état était condamnée en
2020 pour une action climatique
climatique les parlementaires ont
maintes fois insisté sur ce rôle
prépondérant que selon eux devrait jouer
l'hexagone face notamment aussi à des
pays récalcitrants comme la chine l'inde
ou pourquoi pas la russie écouter une
proposition de résolution de ce type en
voit déjà un premier message important
le soutien que la représentation
nationale apporte aux négociateurs
français et européens en leur demandant
de rester les moteurs de la négociation
climatique international de préserver la
dynamique de l'accord de paris accor
complexe et probablement incomplet mais
qui reste à ce stade le seul socle de
négociation multilatéral sur le climat
voilà et en votant cette résolution le
sénat veut aussi dépassé en quelque
sorte le voeu pieux de la simple
résolution en proposant des pistes pour
renforcer la coopération avec les états
du sud vous en avez parlé sur ce plateau
pour notamment résorber les inégalités
en matière de développement c'est un
sujet qui est assez explosif un
plusieurs fois pointé du doigt par les
parlementaires cet après-midi le fameux
le fameux fonds de 100 milliards de
dollars par an qu'on appelle les
financements climat ce fonds qui existe
depuis 2009 et qui a été promis par les
pays du nord et ceux du sud pour
financer leur transition écologique et
bien il n'est pas à ce jour complet
compléter chaque année et donc le compte
n'y est pas et ça aussi certains
sénateurs l'ont dit dans l'hémicycle la
france respecte aujourd'hui ses
engagements en la matière ce n'est pas
le cas de tous les pays la mobilisation
de ces fonds est impérative sans elle il
est illusoire d'espérer que les pays en
développement particulièrement ceux du
continent africain prennent avec nous le
chemin de la neutralité carbone et pour
conclure je vous donne ce bon mot d'un
des parlementaires qu'on a pu recueillir
il ne faudrait pas que la coop de
glasgow finissons douche écossaise voilà
un petit trait d'humour un qui ne fait
jamais de mal vu la gravité des enjeux
effectivement j'ai pas osé lasserre
celle là et je remercie
merci aux parlementaires qui avaient
essayé de faire ma place
je voudrais qu'on nous et j'avais besoin
de cette chronique pour le faire un
chapitre autour de l'action du président
de la république depuis depuis cinq ans
je commence avec vous fabrice bonnifet
quel bilan vous faites du quinquennat
macron bas ils en parlent bien ouais ça
c'est sûr qu'il en parle bien mais le in
fine et c'est l'histoire qui retiendra
aussi oui ou non la france a diminué ses
émissions je pense que tout le monde dit
on j'entends beaucoup de commentateurs
emma la france est exemplaire parce
qu'on a une capacité innée qui nucléaire
mais ce qu'on sait pas c'est que 70 % du
mix énergétique de la france c'est du
faux cils on a la chance d'avoir 30 %
d'électricité duclair d'ailleurs le
nucléaire n'a pas été fait pour pour
émettre moins de co2 c'était pas ça du
tout à l'époque enfin il s'avère que ça
nous aide aussi un peu mais le mix
énergétique de la france et est très
carbonées comme les autres pays
européens pour le transport pour le
chauffage il sera donc nous aussi on
doit on n'est pas exemplaire dans tous
les domaines de la consommation des
énergies fossiles loin s'en faut et donc
on aurait tout intérêt à accélérer la
transition dans notre dodo nos modèles
économiques de nos entreprises parce que
si on devient les grands champions de la
sobriété parce que c'est vraiment le mot
qu'il faut employer et bien c'est une
c'est une stratégie qui peut s'exporter
la sobriété des sociétés dans
l'efficacité énergétique du bâtiment je
sais de quoi je parle dans la rénovation
du bâti public et et privés dans la
sobriété dans les transports aussi
l'année mobilité et les transports il
n'y a pas que le kilowattheure le non
consommées qui coûte le moins cher en
carbone c'est aussi les kilomètres n'ont
effectué est plutôt on va faire basculer
notre industrie vers une industrie de la
résilience et la sobriété plus tôt on
sera capable d'exporter ce savoir faire
sur tous les continents mais pour ça il
faut s'imposer à nous mêmes c'est à dire
mettre en place
soto contraints nous mêmes pour nous
inciter à agir vite sa belle ça
s'appelle une fiscalité du carbone ça
s'appelle aussi des nouveaux usages 2
de la régulation qui peut peut-être
quand je donne un exemple très simple
aujourd'hui on a des bâtiments qui sont
structurellement sous utilisés par des
écoles qui sont utilisés 15 % du temps
20% du temps même des bâtiments
tertiaires pourquoi ne pas inventer
demain une nouvelle forme de fiscalité à
usage plus le bâtiment utilisé par
différents types d'utilisateurs - il
paye deux axes ça inciterait en fait les
propriétaires de bâtiments à trouver des
utilisateurs secondaire pour maximiser
le fonctionnement le fonctionnement de
leurs bâtiments ça nous permettrait
peut-être de construire un peu moins
pour avoir plus de ressources pour
rénover parce que l'important c'est
quand même les 35 millions de logements
à rénover en france on en relève à peine
125 par an il faudrait en rénover 700000
j'ai pas si vous voyez un peu le gap qui
on est on est quand même loin du compte
et donc que ce qu'on a besoin ce qu'on
attend d'un président de la public c'est
de prendre les mesures fortes pour
flécher des financements mais aussi de
la régulation pour accélérer notre
transition parce qu'on en a besoin
arrêtons de dire qu'on est exemplaire en
est exemplaire sur électricité mais on
n'est pas exemplaire sur tous les autres
points plus tôt on sera exemplaire plus
tôt on aura une industrie forte on
pourra exporter dans les autres pays du
monde s'améliorer je vous demande et
vous aussi de faire le bilan vous
l'avais un peu amorcé tout à l'heure en
ce doute il va être assez assez critique
mais avant ça je voudrais proposer deux
interventions du président là publiques
cell à l'ouverture de la cop16 a de la
gouaille et appelons la mise en miroir
avec sa déclaration du 2 juin 2017 on
est juste après le retrait des états
unis de l'accord de paris vous vous
souvenez du mec make our planet great
games est parti toutes les économies
développées doivent désormais contribuer
à leur juste part car le leadership
exige l'exemplarité nous devons nous de
trouver tous les moyens pour que les
pays les plus riches accélèrent ce
financement car nous nous sommes engagés
à mettre sur la table c'est 100
milliards de dollars par an de 2020 à
2025 avant que nous ne mettions encore
davantage après iron your dreams and co
je vous demande de rester confiants nous
réussirons car notre engagement est
total car où que nous vivons lyon qui
que nous soyons nous partageons tous la
même responsabilité
oui
rendre au sa grandeur à notre planète en
planète
s'améliorer l'un des symboles du
quinquennat des manades mâcon c'est le
départ de nicolas hulot de de son
gouvernement vacille quand même
responsable du plaidoyer à la fondation
nicolas hulot oui oui non mais c'est un
des symboles enfin je sais pas je
laisserai les heat aura éditorialistes
faire le cette partie là nous ce qui
nous intéresse à la fin à la fondation
nicolas hulot c'est les chefs et nicolas
il l'avait dit quand il avait quitté le
gouvernement on est sur le bon rythme
sur ao sur aucun sujet lié aux questions
environnementales sur le climat où la
biodiversité est finalement le bilan que
moi je tire c'est quand même le résultat
de la sphère du siècle vous savez celle
là affaire qui a fait condamner l'état
en justice pour une action climatique là
et moi je voudrais me projeter aussi sur
les mois qui viennent puisque l'idée
c'est pas que de faire le bilan du
quinquennat sion site dire il reste
quelques mois l'ouverture de ce concept
derrière les promesses quel acte voilà
qu'est ce qu'on attend l'état a été
condamné
la demande c'est de réduire de 15
millions de tonnes de co2 d'ici 2022 ce
qu'on attend actuellement le sens il
n'ya pas d'astreinte 1 il n'y a pas de
la madame la grande analytique il y aura
la dure à la rioja alors potentiellement
à quelle date on peut être précis la
double il d'où ils ont ils doivent
réduire de 15 millions de tonnes de co2
d'ici le 31 décembre 2022 et donc si
jamais ce n'est pas fait nous les
organisations qui ont attaqué l'état en
justice on refusera et là on espère
qu'il y aura une astreinte si l'état n'a
toujours pas respectés mais la décision
de justice elle est là l'état et donc
c'est de savoir si on est dans un état
de droit et si les responsables
politiques mais modèle macron mais comme
tous les candidats à l'élection
présidentielle on aimerait savoir
cernera emmanuel macron s'il est réélu
ou les autres de savoir comment c'est
quoi leur plan pour tenir cette
obligation de réduire de 15 millions de
tonnes de co2 donc ça c'est le premier
point le second point c'est on va
arriver dans une séquence où la france
va prendre la présidence de l'union
européenne et un stand de sujets qui
sont sur la table donc c'est un peu le
grand le dernier grand dans la grande
chance ponelle macron d'avancé sur ces
questions là et il ya des sujets ou sur
la france pour maman elle bloque
notamment l'appareil de la voiture tout
à l'heure le pays actuellement qui
bloque l'accord pour avoir un accord de
fin de vendre des véhicules diesel et
l'essence dans toute l'europe en 2035
c'est la france qui veut une dérogation
pour aller vous aimez en vers 2015 et
donc ce point là c'est important parce
que si on va en 2040 on tient pas les
objectifs climatiques même 2035 c'est un
peu tard il faudrait aller à 2030 et
laisser une dérogation pour les hybrides
jusqu'à 2035 nous c'est ce qu'on propose
à la fondation nicolas hulot mais c'est
sur ce sujet là qu'on attend maintenant
sur le passé l'état est passé il a été
content la justice est passée l'état a
été condamné donc le bilan finalement il
est fait maintenant sur les sept mois
qui restent sur les quelques mois qui
restent on attend une présentation de
comment est-ce qu'on réduit ses 15
millions de tonnes et une présidence
française l'union européenne qui soit
ambitieuse avec une france qui soit à
l'avant-garde des questions notamment
sur l'action de la voiture pour n'ont
pas abaissé l'ambition de proposer par
la commission européenne mais bien le
relever je voue une parenthèse et puis
après on va parler du poids diplomatique
de mâcon sur ces questions mais
imaginons qu'un candidat ou une
candidate climato-sceptiques l'emportent
à la présidentielle vous croyez vraiment
qu'ils ont respecté la décision de
justice bah c'est la question de savoir
si on est en état de droit j'espère que
vous êtes tous les deux journalistes
vous posez la question à tous les
candidats qui sont là de savoir c'est
quoi votre plan est ce que vous
respectez la justice que pour vous une
décision de justice c'est quelque chose
qu'on doit tenir entendre candidats en
tant que responsable politique je pense
que c'est une vraie question bah
j'espère que le ou la future présidente
de la république elle tiendra cette
promesse sinon ça voudrait dire que nous
on devra redevenir retourner sur vos
tribunaux pour les ressaisir à nouveau
sur cette question sofia cavej le poids
le poids diplomatique d'un emmanuel
macron là effectivement on a entendu une
partie de son discours qui portait sur
le nord sud 1 que vous évoquiez tout
tout à l'heure mais il pèse quoi sur
dans cette coop 26 et d'une mère général
par son bilan peut-être en leadership
européen sur ces questions
alors emmanuel macron il a aussi gagné
du fait que quinquennat précédent avait
eu justement une diplomatie climatique
particulièrement efficace dans le cadre
de la coque d'un t1 j'arrivais de nier
lui en amont avant la tenue de la coop à
de nombreux voyages à de nombreuses
négociations à huis-clos qu'avait fait
que l'accord de paris a été un succès en
tout cas dans son adoption en 2015 donc
il a un petit peu récolter les fruits de
l'image française à l'international
pendant le début de son quinquennat son
mec a great games a été super super
slogan marketing par contre un très bon
coup de com 1 il a été repris par tous
c'est quelque chose qui parle aux
américains notamment voilà c'est quelque
chose ça par les américains qui était
pas satisfait du fait de leur taille
soit sortie de l'accord de paris
notamment et puis aussi un leadership au
sein à l'union européenne un leadership
autres proclamer un faut le dire aussi
parce que dans les actions on se rend
compte qu'on n'est pas du tout sur la
trajectoire aujourd'hui quand même la
france en a pris un coup de cette
condamnation la france ce pays qui
finalement 1 arrive à être condamné
l'état français par ses propres
instances juridiques pour inaction donc
en effet l'image en est quand même un
peu ternie mais la france demeure un
acteur important dans la diplomatie
climatique de parts aussi le réseau qui
n'a pas su tisser au fil des ans de par
son statut diplomatique de base ça dure
c'est quand même un pays qui est un
siège de sécurité conseil de sécurité de
l'onu donc il est il est quand même très
actif avec un réseau diplomatique
internationale conséquent donc la france
a un rôle à jouer important et à la un
rôle notamment au sein de l'union
européenne notamment suite au départ du
royaume-uni qui avait aussi un point
important fabrice bonnifet cette
procédure dite de de la sphère du siècle
est ce que il faut aller jusque là
finalement pour pour contraindre pour
contraindre les états y avait eu un
précédent aux pays bas il faut le il
faut le rappeler a été dit à leur part
se fier à ça fait 26 ans qu'on négocie
un mois je pense que dans cette merde
c'est nicolas hulot qui parlait de la
d'une métaphore ddd réunion de
copropriétaires il ya 200 pays qui sont
à l'onu à peu près ils sont d'accord sur
rien ce que je disais tout à l'heure et
les pays producteurs les pays
consommateurs et
les uns ont besoin des autres est arrivé
à se mettre d'accord les uns et les
autres sur sur un consensus dans ce
domaine là c'est impossible la preuve
c'est que ça fait 25 ans qu'on essaye on
n'y arrive pas il faut quand même
rappeler une chose c'est que y'a que 10%
des habitants de cette planète qui
émettent 50% des émissions 10% donc en
réalité on fait partie nous les français
comme les pays occidentaux de ceux qui
polluent le plus c'est pour permettre à
ceux qui essayent de se développer
depuis des années d'accéder à un minimum
de biens matériels il faut que nous on a
on accepte de moins consommer d'eau -
émettre de co2 pour permettre d'en
émettre un peu plus donc nous se
comptent plus d'efforts à faire c'est
nous et si on comprend pas ça on n'a pas
compris en fait l'accord de paris donc
ça veut dire que cette mise au régime
climatique cette mise au régime en
termes d'émissions des adversaires il
faut la rendre désirable et en fait
c'est avant tout un enjeu social
comment arriver à continuer de payer des
salaires en émettant de moins en moins
de co2 parce que le co2 c'est de
l'énergie qui rentrent dans les machines
et c'est les machines qui font la
production qui font la création de
richesse donc si on veut demain y
arriver arrêter de se mentir à soi-même
il va falloir réinventer des indicateurs
de création de richesse aujourd'hui
celui qu'on utilise à longueur de temps
dans les médias le fameux pib il faut
leur questionner rapidement il faut
aussi mettre en place un nouveau système
comptable dans les entreprises
aujourd'hui le système comptable
d'entreprise ne vise qu'à préserver le
capital financier c'est bien il faut
créer l'extra financier il faut le créer
kabyle et la préservation du capital
naturel parce qu en fait une entreprise
c'est ni plus ni moins qu'une machine
qui transforme des matières premières
avec de l'énergie des convertisseurs ddd
des machines pour créer de la valeur
donc il faut intégrer la valeur d'une
entreprise son bilan sociétal son bilan
environnement sûr et que ai demandé aux
entreprises de tenir compte de la de la
déplétion des ressources de la
préservation des écosystèmes dans leur
modèle d'affaires et que les citoyens
acceptent aussi de payer le juste prix
pour ça parce qu'on est tous contents
d'acheter un t-shirt à 2 euros le samedi
matin mais c'est quoi la variable
d'ajustement de ses traits à coups mais
c'est vrai que justement c'est du social
mais c'est l'environnement nous écoute
là et quand ils sont à deux euros près à
la fin du ring qui entendent pas votre
argument oui mais cet argument in fine
et ça se retourne contre nous parce que
à force de dire voilà on va ne pas payer
ce qu'on doit la nature on en arrive à
une situation ubuesque au rythme actuel
des émissions mondiales la planète sera
dans certaines parties du monde
inhabitables bien avant la fin de ce
siècle avec des migrations climatiques
qui peuvent faire peur à certains et qui
sera intenable d'un point de vue social
donc au bout d'un moment il ya aussi un
discours de vérité qu'il faut tenir aux
gens de sans doute moins consommer pour
mieux consommer et avoir une attitude
dans la gestion des entreprises qui sera
centré de plus en plus sur l'éradication
des externats négative au profit
dextérité positive mais sans variable
d'ajustement environnementale et sociale
donc c'est une reconfiguration du modèle
d'affaires en fait qu est importante il
ya une phrase intéressante dans ce que
vous disais que je retiens c'est se
mettre au régime à se mettre au régime
en termes d'émissions de sa fille
devienne son et originaux vous disiez
est-ce que et on l'a peut-être question
pour vous au sens des relations
internationales il ya aussi ça derrière
les réticences de certains pays du sud
il ya aussi cette le fait de se dire les
pays du nord se sont gavés pendant des
siècles des années handicap dès
maintenant qu'on arrive dans nous est la
société de consommation un certain
confort là on nous dit fini ceinture
tout le monde au régime alors ce que
vous décrivez en fait c'est entériné
dans le cadre de la convention cadre des
nations unies pour changement climatique
serré entériné dans le cadre de la porte
de paris c'est le principe de
responsabilités communes mais
différenciées et de capacités
respectives techniquement français
revoit le terme faire leur
juste nous dire en fait que dépendamment
consent à payer développés ou en
développement on n'a pas contribué de la
même manière à la situation à laquelle
on se trouve aujourd'hui c'est à dire le
taux de concentration actuelle de gaz à
effet de serre dans l'atmosphère et on
n'a pas les mêmes capacités d'adaptation
c'est pour ça qu'il ces fameux 100
milliards et sont importants c'est parce
qu'ils n'ont pas tous les mêmes
capacités financières de pouvoir mettre
en oeuvre la transition nécessaire de
leur société de leur économie mais
également de répondre aux impacts socali
font d'ores et déjà face parce que ça il
faut aussi en parler on parle dans le
futur comment on va faire mais c'est
maintenant que ces pays font face à des
phénomènes de sécheresse à des
phénomènes d'inondation comme c'est le
cas pour nous en europe sauf qu'ici on a
beaucoup plus de capacités financières
de moyens de réponse même de moyens de
réponse d'urgence pour répondre à ces
situations là et donc en effet c'est
souvent ce qui cadre d'ailleurs la
négociation en termes d'accès par
exemple les transferts de technologies
en termes d'accès à des financements
cette catégorisation entre pays
développés et en développement elle est
cruciale parce que c'est un enjeu de
justice on m'a pas demandé la même chose
à des états qui ne pas contribuer de la
même manière mais la chine ont l'âme et
où par exemple alors justement c'est
quelque chose qui est très la russie
n'est pas représentée par son chef
d'état délégation je suis d'ailleurs
petite anecdote sur la chine en effet le
président donc n'y est pas associée pas
rendu faut quand même ça remettre ça
dans le contexte la crise sanitaire il
n'est pas sorti son territoire depuis le
début de la crise sanitaire d'une part
et d'autre part il avait déclaré vouloir
donner une allocution en vidéo cette
allocution vidéo lui aurait été refusé
par la présidence britannique de la coop
parce que le cadre du world des deux
semaines demandé aux chefs d'état de se
rendre physiquement et donc il ya eu en
tout cas voilà de ce qu'on peut lire
dans la presse
dépendamment qu'on voit les médias
chinois et européens on va pas la même
chose donc ça c'est assez intéressant
pour revenir au statut de la chine là
dessus de la chine dans la négociation
elle s'exprime avec le g77 le juste sont
17 c'est quoi ce sont les pays les plus
pauvres du monde et elle fait encore
partie des pays considérés en
développement alors même qu en effet
d'un point de vue aux démissions c'est
le premier émetteur de gaz à effet de
serre de loin mais son développement
a eu lieu en fait beaucoup plus tard que
les nations dites des pays du nord donc
comme c'est le cas de la france d' union
européenne dans sa globalité des états
unis et donc la chine considère qu'elle
fait sa part mais qu'elle n'est pas
celle qui doit le faire le plus parce
qu'elle s'est passé
mais peut-être sur la chine ce qu'il
faut toujours rappeler c'est
qu'effectivement c'est le premier
amateur mais ils produisent aussi pour
le reste de la planète c'est à dire que
nous en france
50% de nos émissions sont des émissions
à porter dont elles ne sont pas
comptabilisés dans nos émissions mais on
les importe ces produits donc c'est bien
nous qui récoltons les fruits ou qui
pouvant profiter de ce qui a été produit
en partie par les chinois dont il ya
aussi à un peu un double discours à
vouloir mettre la faute sur les chinois
alors que c'est nous qui avons fait des
choix politiques de désindustrialise les
l'union européenne pour exporter nos
pollutions et aujourd'hui on ré importe
ces sujets donc on a un vrai sujet
diplomatique peut-être pour revenir sur
ce sujet la gare niveau dernier mot mais
très rapidement parce que le problème de
l' architecture de paris de l'accord de
paris c'est que on prend des engagements
mais ne sont pas même si on les tient
pas on n'est pas sanctionné non
clairement donné à falloir mettre toutes
les politiques publiques au service de
la transition y compris la politique
commerciale actuellement les enceintes
du commerce international sont
complètement discuter ailleurs à paris
lors de la com 21 la commission
européenne est venue comme tous les
états avec comme obligation de ne pas
prendre de mesures qui pourraient
entraver le développement du commerce
international
donc on a besoin de lier les engagements
climatiques également à des sanctions
donc de dire à bolton arrow de dire
peut-être demain si on a un candidat au
canada qui veut sortir de l'accord de
paris un moment donné si vous tenez pas
vos objectifs eh ben on arrêtera de
commercer avec vous et on fermera note
accès nous l'union européenne à notre
marché si vous tenez pas vos objectifs
climatiques va falloir aussi renforcé ça
c'est un sujet qu'un train de monter
actuellement nous c'est une de nos
propositions phares à la fondation
nicolas hulot et on pense qu'on tiendra
pas nos objectifs climatiques si on
revoit pas notre politique commerciale
internationale merci beaucoup merci à
tous les trois d'avoir participé à ce
débat